qui sera le candidat des verts à
l'élection présidentielle ce jeudi début
du premier tour des primaires
écologistes chez les verts la primaire
ça existe depuis 2001 et à chaque fois
ça a été un moment disons tumultueux et
c'est moi vous demander de bien vouloir
laisser au vestiaire les couteaux et les
fusils retour en juin 2001 à l'époque
alain lipietz gagne la primaire trace à
noël mamère mais quelques semaines plus
tard l'écologie se tient ces propos très
controversés sur l'amnistié des
nationalistes corses évidemment il y
aura amnistie à un moment donné c'est
comme ça dans toutes les guerres civiles
dans tous les processus de violence une
fois qu'on a réglé les problèmes on
passe l'épongé chez les verts ces propos
ne passe pas après un référendum interne
lipietz est évincé c'est noël mamère qui
le remplace en effet le député maire de
bègles a finalement été convaincu par
ses proches et dominique voynet il
portera bien les couleurs vertes sur
l'élection présidentielle cinq ans plus
tard en 2006 nouvelle primaire chez les
verts au second tour dominique voynet
face à yves cochet n'arriverai pas à me
faire dire des choses agréables sur yves
cochet il a plein de défauts mais je
garde pour moi
jusqu'ici tout va bien mais au second
tour les deux candidats se retrouvent
quasiment à égalité
résultat on prend les mêmes et on
recommence
un second tour est à nouveau organisée
voynet en sort vainqueur mais non sans
mal 59 59 % des suffrages exprimés
à
50,59
2011 la primaire vire au règlement de
comptes
la scène se passe à paris lors d'un
débat public entre les quatre candidats
l'ancien animateur télé nicolas hulot
est sévèrement taclé par stéphane lhomme
le tout sous le regard gêné d'eva joly
et l'élu et des sympathisants donc c'est
quelqu'un qui nous arrive de la planète
qui a fort
et dans l'image est indissociable de
celle des multinationales qui ont été
ses mécènes pendant des années aucun des
deux candidats ne sera élu c'est eva
joly qui remporte la primaire
en 2016 yannick jadot sort vainqueur de
la primaire écologiste chez les verts la
question d'une alliance avec le ps le
pause mais pour jadot il en est hors de
question avec le monde compte du
hollandisme à gauche c'est pas notre
c'est pas aujourd'hui notre combat trois
mois plus tard yannick jadot se ravise
au 20 heures de france 2 alors oui ce
soir je retire ma candidature c'est ce
sur quoi voteront tous ceux qui ont
participé à la primaire écologiste en
2021 ils sont cinq à se présenter à la
primaire écologiste pour voter deux
conditions être âgé d'au moins 16 ans et
débourser deux euros
[Musique]